okay we have a funny voice mail for you
today the I don't know if people are now
starting to troll me I don't think so
from the content of this voicemail but
you've got to turn your radio down or
pause the podcast when you call in
here's another caller who calls then
with my voice blaring in the background
take a listen remember the phone number
two one nine two david p call any time
of day even in the middle of the night
as this gentleman did oh that was your
past maternity call back i'm just a
chance caught the program I can't
believe the idiots are calling you and
talking to you're wasting your time with
put stories that people with funny
accents and stuff like that but apart
from that I'm interested in your opinion
on denier yes Nielsen's or book war
against all America all Puerto Ricans
I've read the book and would like your
opinion on that I don't know what it is
but hearing my own voice so loudly in
the background with the caller having to
strain their voice to talk over it it
cracks me up
but remember turn your radio down pause
the podcast as far as the book this
gentleman is asking about I have not
read it so I would not be able to
comment on the bonus show today
Republicans could lose the Senate we're
going to talk about how it could happen
we're going to talk about what are the
important metrics to look at as of right
now we've been covering the Twenty
twenty Senate election big picture for
over a year it was not looking good at
all for Democrats for quite some time
the coronavirus Fiasco and Trump's
mishandling could more notably open the
door for Democrats to take control of
the Senate in November number two China
is installing surveillance cameras
outside people's front doors for
quarantine isolation purposes and in
some cases even inside people's cameras
we're going to talk about the
circumstances and the legal basis for
that and lastly a court has ruled
that detroit students have a
constitutional right to an education
what does that mean and what are the
practical implications we will discuss
that on today's bonus show I will be
joined by David Pakman show producer Pat
Forde and we will see how his quarantine
is holding up sign up today and get
instant access to the bonus show two
ways to do it become a member at join
pakman.com coupon code 2020 now we'll
save you
66% off of the cost of a membership
that's one way to get access to the
bonus show the other way to get access
is to become a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show both extremely
valued and really appreciate everybody
who has signed up or contributed one way
or the other over the last couple of
weeks I will speak to you on the bonus
show or otherwise we'll be back with a
brand new program tomorrow